สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนเรเรียกลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนใน
ช่อง comprehensible ไยเย้ๆครับผมครูเอ๋
สอนไป 1 คลิปอ่าเป็นยังไงสอนไป 1 คลิป
แล้วเป็นยังไงเจ็บคอเหรอคิดอ๋อไม่ใช่ค่ะ
คิดว่าเสียงจะไม่เหมือน
กันเสียงจะเบาไปมั้ยคะอ๋อโอเคอ้าค่ะครู
อาตี้คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะเจอกันอ่าวันนี้
เรามาเจอกันก็ต้องเป็นวันจันทร์สิครับได้
ปฏิทินครัวที่ี้ไปไหนสีฟ้าแล้วร่ะคะครัว
ที่ี้เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนสีแบคกราวเป็นสีฟ้า
ให้คล้ายๆกับสีเสื้ออ๋อครูเอกก็สีชมพูและ
สีแดงๆส้มๆนะคะเป็นผู้ชายวันจันทวันนี้
วันจันทร์โอเควันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 29
ครับเดือนอะไรคะอ่าเดือนนี้
เดือนเดือนสิงหาคมครับเดือน 8 ค่ะอปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะอ่าค.ศ
2022 เยตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้ใช่มย
เดี๋ยวโกตี้ดูเวลาก่อนเดี๋ยวนะอ้อนี่ไง
อ่าตอนนี้ 19 น
194  15 นอื
1945 นแล้วอ่าใช่ครับ 19:45 นแล้วครับอื
สำหรับคลิปนี้ก็จะไปอ๋อธุรกิจค่ะไม่ได้ไป
อ๋ออ่าไปๆๆเดี๋ยวไปเหออ๋อวันนี้ต้องไปใช่
มั้ครูเอดต้องไปใช่มั้โอเคค่ะไปไหนไปไหนู
อันตี้ให้ครูเอดไปใช่มั้ยคะงั้นครูเอดลุก
แล้วก็เดินแล้วนะคะอ่าไปไหนครับไปไหนไป
ไหนคะอืมออครูอตี้ครูเอ๋กคิดได้
ครับคือครูเอ๋กน่ะชอบทำอาหารออครูอาตี้
ชอบมั้ยอ่าชอบครับครููอตี้ก็ทำอาหารแล้ว
ที่บ้านครูอาตี้ก็มีเด็กๆเนาะมีๆๆ 2 คน 4
คนเด็กๆก็กำลังกินใช่มั้ยฮะใช่กินเยอะ
ด้วยกินเยอะกินเยอะอใช่กำลังจะโตนะกิน
เยอะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็ต้องซื้ออาหารเยอะๆใช่
มั้ยใช่ซื้ออาหารมาเก็บไว้เพราะว่าจะได้
ไม่ต้องไปตลาดบ่อยๆไม่อยากไปบ่อยใช่เพตอน
นี้ก็เนาะฝนตกนะคะตกเราก็ไม่อยากไปตลาด
บ่อยๆอ่าเราจะไปตลาดนะคะนักเรียนเราไม่
ได้ไปซุปเปอร์นะบางคนก็ไปซุปเปอร์ก็ได้นะ
คะแต่ถ้าซื้อบางอย่างตลาดเนี่ยจะใหม่กว่า
มั้ยครับอืสดกว่าครับใช่ทีนี้เนี่ยเราก็
ต้องมีที่เก็บครูอตี้อ่านั่นก็คืออ่าอะไร
ครับเก็บในอะไรครับเก็บในเก็บในในอะไรคะ
ครูอัติในในตู้ไงในตู้กับข้าวเฮ้ยเดี๋ยว
ครูอาตี้หมูไก่่สดๆใส่ตู้กับข้าวหรอคะออ
ถ้าหมูไก่สดๆใส่ตู้กับข้าวไม่ได้ต้องใส่
ตู้ตู้เย็นครับตู้
เย็นใช่ๆมีตู้เย็นมั้ยคะอ่ามีตู้เย็นน่ะ
ครูอตี้มีตู้เย็นมาขายครับวันนี้ออ่า
เพราะว่าตู้เย็นครูเอ๋มันเล็กแล้วอ่ะครู
เอ๋อยากจะเปลี่ยนอืมเปลี่ยนตยอยากจะ
เปลี่ยนตู้เย็นครูเอ๋นั่งก่อนนะคะครูเออ๋
เดินไปแล้วนะคะไปอ่าเรามานั่งข้างครับอ่า
เดี๋ยวครูอตี้จะเป็นเอ่อเป็นเป็นคนขายตู้
เย็นดีมั้ยดีค่ะดีอ่าแล้วครูเออ๋เป็นลูก
ค้าใช่มั้ยเป็นลูกค้าที่ไม่เข้าใจตู้เย็น
แต่อยากได้ตู้เย็นใหม่แต่ไม่รู้หรอกไม่
รู้จักหรอกตู้เย็นเป็นยังไงเดี๋ยวคูตี้
แนะนำให้คูตี้เอ่อจขายตู้เย็นให้ครูเอ๋นะ
ครับวันนี้นักเรียนใช่ตู้เย็นแบบไหนดีนะ
คะออืโอเคครูเอ๋ก็เดินไปละไปที่ห้างครับ
อะไรก็ได้นะอืที่มีเอ่อกู้เย็นขายกู้เย็น
ค่ะอครับอ่าสวัสดีครับคุณลูกค้าอ่าคุณลูก
ค้ากำลังเอ่อดูสินค้าอะไรอยู่ครับสอ๋อพี่
อยากดูตู้เย็นใหม่สักเครื่องนึงออ๋อตู้
เย็นใหม่สักเครื่องนึงอ้อแล้วตอนนี้คุณ
ลูกค้าใช้เอ่อตู้เย็น
เอ่อตู้เย็นกี่คิวหรอคะกี่คิวจะถามว่ากี่
คิวไกลัวตี้คิดนักเรียนจะงงมยกี่คิวกี่
คิวโอเเอ่อเ่อพี่ก็ไม่รู้กี่คิวน้องมัน
สูงประมาณพี่อ่ะแล้วก็กว้างประมาณเนี้ย
อ๋ออ๋อขนาดประมาณ
นี้เ่อคุณลูกค้าที่บ้านที่บ้านคุณลูกค้า
อยู่กันกี่คนครับออ 2 คนค่ะอ๋ออยู่ 2 คน
ใช่มั้ยถ้าอยู่ 2 คนแล้วปกติคุณลูกค้า
ซื้ออาหารครั้งนึงซื้อเยอะหรือซื้อนิด
หน่อยครับ
อ่าตอนเกินอาหารที่บ้าน 1 วัน 2-3 มื้อนะ
คะเอ่าคือชอบกิน
ผลไม้ชอบกินผักก็ซื้อเยอะนะคะอ๋ออผัก
สัปดาห์ละประมาณ 3-4 กกอ่ะค่ะอืโอ้ก็แสดง
ว่าเ่อคุณลูกค้าก็ต้องการตู้เย็นที่ไซส์
ขนาดใหญ่หน่อยนะครับใช่ตอนเนี้ย 5 คิว
เนี่ยมันเล็กเกินไปออ 5 คิวเล็กเกินไปอ๋อ
โอเคโอเคอือฮึแล้วพี่อยากได้ตู้เย็นที่
ไม่มีน้ำแข็งอ่ะไม่เป็นน้ำแข็งอ่ะออได้
ครับมีมีตู้เย็นที่ไม่มีน้ำแข็งแต่ว่าเ่อ
สำหรับตู้เย็นที่ไม่มีน้ำแข็งเนี่ยก็จะ
เป็นเอ่อรุ่นที่ขนาดใหญ่ขึ้นมาหน่อยอาจจะ
ประมาณ 10 คิวค่ะขึ้นไปนะครับ 2  2 ประตู
ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าเป็น 2 ประตูใช่ครับจะมีระบบ
ที่ไม่มีน้ำแข็งเกาะใช่เพราะว่าขี้เกียจ
แงะน้ำแข็งอ่าขี้เกียจกดปุ่มละลายแล้วก็
ต้องรอรอให้น้ำแข็งละลายใช่มยใช่พอละลาย
เสร็จมันก็จะล้นออกมาต้องเช็ดเช็ดเช็ด
เช็ดกับโอ๊ยเช็ดน้ำอีกเบื่อมากอืมครับ
ครับงั้นเมีตู้เย็นแบบไหนแนะนำพี่อ่ามี
ตู้เย็นหลายแบบให้เลือกครับอ่าถ้าเป็นตู้
เย็นไซส์เล็กอ่าแบบนี้ที่เอ่อคุณลูกค้า
ไม่อยากกดปุ่มละลายน้ำแข็งอ๋อพี่ไม่ชอบสี
แดงอ่ะอก็ต้องเอาตู้เย็นที่ขนาดใหญ่ขึ้น
มาหน่อยอืนะครับอ่าแบบนี้จะมี 2 ประตู 2
ประตูใช่ครับเอ๊ะแล้วช่องแช่แข็งนี่อยู่
ข้างบนหรือข้างล่างคะอเอ่อเรามีตู้เย็น
หลายแบบแบบที่ช่องแช่แข็งอยู่ด้านบนอยู่
ด้านบนหรืออยู่ด้านล่างแบบนี้ก็มีใช่เอ๊
แล้วอย่างไหนมันสบายกว่าน้องอ๋อเอ่อต้อง
เ่อถ้าคุณลูกค้าปกติคุณลูกค้าเปิดตู้เย็น
คุณลูกค้าหยิบอะไรบ่อยๆครับหยิบผักสลัด
หยิบน้ำอืหยิบผลไม้ค่ะโอเคถ้าหยิบผักหยิบ
ผลไม้บ่อยๆเนี่ยเอ่อผมแนะนำให้คุณลูกค้า
ซื้อตู้เย็นแบบที่ช่องแช่แข็งอยู่ข้าง
ล่างครับออทำไมอ่ะคะเพราะว่าคุณลูกค้าไม่
ต้องก้มอ๋อคุณลูกค้ายืนคุณลูกค้าก็สามารถ
หยิบผักหยิบผลไม้ได้เลยไม่ต้องก้มอือ่า
แต่ถ้าคุณลูกค้าซื้อแบบช่องแช่แข็งอยู่
ด้านบนค่ะคุณลูกค้าต้องก้มครับต้องก้มมา
หยิบผักผักจะอยู่ช่องล่างสุดใช่แล้วมันจะ
ปวดหลังเพราะว่าอายุมากแล้วใช่ครับต้อง
ซื้อแบบช่องฟรีซอยู่ข้างล่างเพราะว่าเรา
ไม่ค่อยหยิบไก่ไม่ค่อยหยิบหมูหยิบไม่บ่อย
ใช่ค่ะหยิบไก่หยิบหมูเนี่ยก็ 1 วัน 1
ครั้งใช่อ่าเพราะว่าเช้าไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์
กลางวันไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์กินเฉพาะตอนเย็น
อ้อนะค่ะอื
เอ๊แล้ว
ราคามันต่างกันมั้ยคะอ่าราคาไม่ต่างกัน
ครับอือ่าไม่ต่างกันราคาใกล้เคียงกันแตก
ต่างกันนิดหน่อยนะครับอ๋อแบบไหนแพงกว่า
อ่าปกติแบบนี้จะเป็นแบบทั่วไปที่เอ่อคุณ
ลูกค้าจะเห็นตู้เย็นทั่วไปก็จะมีช่องแช่
แข็งเนี่ยอยู่ด้านบนราคาก็จะถูกกว่านิด
หน่อยค่ะค่ะอ่าใช่ครับเอ๊ะเอ่อเดี๋ยวนะ
แล้วความจุข้างในอ่ะคือคือที่ดูเนี่ยช่อง
แช่แข็งข้างล่างเนี่ยอ่าสามารถใส่ใส่
อาหารได้มากกว่ามยคะอ่าเอ่อขนาดเท่ากัน
ครับเท่ากันนะครับอ่าสามารถเลือกได้เอ่อ
เวลาที่เราวัดขนาด Q ของตู้เย็นเนี่ย
ปริมาตรของตู้เย็นเราจะ
วัดแค่ช่องที่ไม่ได้เป็นท่องฟีดอ๋อค่ะอ้า
ใช่ครับออแล้วการระบายความร้อนอ่าระบาย
ความเย็นในตู้เย็นใช่มั้ยครับมีมีความ
ร้อนกับความ
เย็นการละบายความร้อนของตู้เย็นอ้าปกติ
คุณลูกค้าไม่ๆเพราะว่ามันจะมีเครื่องไงคะ
บางรุ่นเนี่ยเข้าบอกว่าความร้อนออกด้าน
ข้างอความรุ่นความร้อนออกด้านหลังอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะครับอันนี้ออกข้างๆเออกข้างหลัง
ค่ะอ่าอันนี้จะออกรอบๆตู้เย็นครับอ๋อ
เพราะว่าคุณลูกค้าบอกว่าอยากได้ตู้เย็น
แบบที่ไม่ต้องแงะน้ำแข็งออกออค่ะอ่าเราจะ
ทำเ่อตู้เย็นรุ่นนี้เนี่ยจะทำให้มีความ
ร้อนรอบๆตู้เย็นอือ่าอยู่รอบๆตู้เย็นเลย
ค่ะแล้วเมื่อกี้พูดถึงการระบายความเย็น
ครับการระบายความเย็นก็คือการที่เอ่อตู้
เย็นเนี่ยเอ่อทำให้อากาศอากาศที่เย็นๆใน
ตู้เย็นน่ะหมุนหมุนเวียนไปให้ทั่วให้ทั่ว
ตู้เย็นแบบนี้ครับอ๋อแล้วมันสม่ำเสมอมคะ
อ่าใช่ครับเอ่อระบบเราจะมีระบบระบายความ
เ่อเย็นให้ทั่วถึงมีช่องช่องปล่อยความ
เย็นออกทุกๆเอ่อที่ในตู้เย็นเนี่ยเท่ากัน
อ่าเพราะว่าอะไรรู้มั้ยที่พี่ถามเพราะว่า
ตู้เย็นปัจจุบันของพี่เนี่ยครับเป็นยังไง
ครับเป็นน้ำ
แข็งเป็นเป็นน้ำแข็งแล้วเป็นน้ำ
แข็งแบบนี้มยครับเป็นน้ำแข็งแบบนี้มั้ย
ใช่เป็นน้ำแข็งแบบนี้โอ้โหยอันนี้ก็คือใน
ช่องในช่องแช่แข็งใช่มั้ยในช่องแช่แข็ง
เป็นน้ำแข็งแต่ว่าช่องอื่นช่องที่อื่นไม่
เป็นน้ำแข็งใช่มั้ยคือคือคือคือคือแบบนี้
ค่ะคือนานนะคะครับคือพอล้างน้ำแข็งออก
ปั๊บเนี่ยครับอืแล้วเสียบปลั๊กเอ้ยเวลา
ล้างน้ำแข็งพี่ดึงปลั๊กออกเนี่ยถูกหรือ
ผิดคะเอ่อถูกแล้วครับถูกใช่มั้ยครับควรจะ
ดึงใช่มั้ยคะอือฮึอ่าพอเอาน้ำแข็งออกปั๊บ
เนี่ยแล้วพอเสียบปลั๊กใหม่อ่ะค่ะครับ
อ่าทั้งทั้งหมดเนี่ยเย็นมากเลยค่ะอ๋อแล้ว
ก็ผัก
พี่แข็งเลยอ่ะค่ะผักก็จะกลายเป็นน้ำแข็ง
ไปด้วยใช่มั้ยครับเพราะว่าเย็นความเย็น
ออกมาเยอะมากใช่มั้ยครับใช่เปัญหาพี่ไม่
ได้เปิดแบบอะไรนะมันมีเบอร์ใช่มั้ยคะ 1  2
3  4  5 เปิดนิดเดียวเปิดนิดเดียวก็เย็น
มากใช่มั้ยใช่หลังจากเอาน้ำแข็งออกอ่ะนะ
งั้นตู้ที่แบ่งเป็น 2 ประตูเนี่ยดีกว่า
ประตูเดียวตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยคะที่ได้ยิน
เพื่อนบอกออึอือฮึใช่บอกว่าถ้า 2 ประตู
เนี่ยจะไม่เป็นน้ำแข็งก็คือผักจะไม่เป็น
จะไม่แข็งอ่าใช่ครับเพราะว่าเขาคแยกแยก
เอ่อแยกส่วนข้างล่างเป็นช่องแช่แข็งใช่
มั้ยข้างล่างก็จะเป็นน้ำแข็งค่ะส่วนข้าง
บนก็จะไม่เป็นน้ำแข็งใช่ครับเขาจะแยกกัน
อ่าอันนี้ดีกว่าเนาะอนี้กี่ประตูคะเนี่ย
อันนี้เอ่อ 4 ประตูครับเปิด 4 ด้านมี 4
ประตูแต่ก็มีรุ่นที่เป็น 2 ประตูก็ทำงาน
ใช้ระบบระบายความเย็นแบบนี้เหมือนกันครับ
รุ่นนะคะบางทีก็พูดอันบางทีก็พูดรุ่นนะ
คะได้ครับคนไทยใช้หน่วยนับเอ่อบางครั้ง
เราก็ไม่อยากพูดชื่อรุ่นไม่อยากพูดชื่อ
ของสิ่งนั้นหลายๆครั้งเราก็ใช้อันนั้นอัน
นี้อันนั้นใช่เอ๊ะรุ่น 2 ประตูกับ 4
ประตูเนี่ยครับดีต่างกันยังไงอ่ะคะอ๋อถ้า
เป็นรุ่น 4 ประตูจะเป็นขนาดใหญ่ใหญ่มากอ
อ่าประมาณประมาณ 20 คิวขึ้นไปอืออ้าแต่
บ้านน้องเนี่ยใช้รุ่นกี่ประตูคะอ่าถ้า
เป็นบ้านของคุณลูกค้าบ้านของคุณลูกค้า
อยู่กันแค่ 2 คนนะครับอ่าแล้วก็ไปตลาดใช้
เอ่อเก็บอาหารประมาณ 3-4  ,000 ใช้ 2
ประตูพอแล้วครับพอแล้วนะคะแต่พี่ชอบทำขนม
ด้วยนะอ๋อทำขนมด้วยก็สมมุติว่าถ้าพี่อยาก
ทำเค้กออันนี้คิดคนเดียวใช่มั้ยคะครับ
โอเคเชิญค่ะน้อง
ขาเชิญน้องแนะนำต่อค่ะอ่าโอเค
ก็ก็มีรุ่น 4 ประตูนะคะอันนี้จะใหญ่หน่อย
นะคะถ้าสมมติสมมติว่าพี่ชอบทำเค้กครับ
สมมตินะคะนักเรียนอชอบทำเค้กก็ควรจะซื้อ
รุ่นใหญ่เลยใช่มั้ยคะจะได้มีที่เก็บขนมอ
ก็ใช่ครับใช่ครับถ้ายิ่งใหญ่มากก็ยิ่งมี
พื้นที่ในการเก็บขนมเยอะแต่แต่ถ้ายิ่ง
ใหญ่มากราคาก็จะสูงขึ้นสูงขึ้นแพงขึ้นใช่
มครับค่ะอืเอ่อรุ่น 4 ประตูเนี่ยประมาณ
เท่าไหร่ค่ะอ่ารุ่น 4 ประตูก็ราคาประมาณ
ประมาณ 100,000 ครับ 120,000
ใช่ครับ 4 ประตูจะแพงกว่าเยอะแงมากใช่ๆออ
เดี๋ยวๆรุ่นนี้ทำน้ำแข็งด้วยหรือเปล่าคะ 1
ทำน้ำแข็งด้วยครับอ่ามีระบบทำน้ำแข็งเรา
แค่เติมน้ำเปล่าเข้าไปอ๋ออ่าแล้วก็มีน้ำ
แข็งออกมาอัตโนมัติไม่ต้องทำเอง
อ๋อแล้วก็รุ่นไม่ต้องไม่อกดน้ำดื่มได้ใช่
มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับถ้าเป็นรุ่น 4 ประตูจะ
สามารถกดน้ำดื่มได้จากข้างนอกไม่ต้องเปิด
ไม่ต้องเปิดตู้เย็นออกมาอืเอาแก้วกดน้ำ
ได้เลยอืเอ๊แล้วเรื่องเชื้อราในตู้เย็น
ล่ะคะครับอรุ่นนี้จะดีกว่ารุ่นแบบปกติม
อ่าดีกว่าครับเพราะว่ามีระบบอ่าระบบอ่า
กำจัดเชื้อราด้วยครับอืกำจัดเชื้อราเชื้อ
แบคทีเรียเใช่ครับกำจัดเชื้อแบคทีเรีย
กำจัดกลิ่นด้วยเวลาเราใส่ไก่ใส่หมูใส่
เอ่ออาหารสดเข้าไปก็จะมีตัวดูดกลิ่นเข้า
ไปเก็บไว้ไม่ให้กลิ่นเอ่อกระจายไปในตู้
เย็นใช่อ๋อเท่าที่เห็นในนั้นน่ะเหมือนกับ
จะแต่ละชั้นก็จะมีตัวล็อคมีฝาปิดหรอคะอ่า
มีช่องมีช่องอยู่ครับช่องนี้อาจจะเก็บไก่
ทั้งตัวช่องนี้อาจจะเก็บเ่อหมูเก็บผักนะ
ครับเก็บแยกชั้นของใครก็ชั้นของเอ่อของ
สิ่งนั้นไม่ปนกันอืค่ะอ๋อสมควรแก่ราคาแสน
กว่าอ่าใช่ครับถ้าต้องการเอ่อเก็บอาหาร
เยอะๆก็ใช้ตู้เย็นขนาดใหญ่แต่เอ่อของเอ่อ
ของผมเองนะของผมเองที่ผมใช้เองผมก็ใช้
ประมาณ 2 ประตูครับ 2 ประตูอือื 2 ประตู
ราคาเท่าไหร่คะเนี่ยอ่า 2 ประตูราคาก็
ประมาณ 20,000 บาทครับไม่แพงเท่าไหร่ออ
อ้อโอเคค่ะงั้นเอาเอาราคาแสนวางไว้ก่อน
วางเดี๋ยวรอเดี๋ยวรอให้มีลูกมีครอบครัวมา
อยู่ด้วยกันหลายๆคนอ่าค่อยขยายให้เป็น
ขนาดใหญ่ขึ้นออ่าเอน้องว่าพี่ก็ปรึกษา
หน่อยพี่สมมุติว่าพี่มีครอบครัวใหญ่หลาย
คนพี่ควรจะซื้อรุ่น 4 ประตูครับหรือว่า
พี่ควรจะซื้อเ่อรุ่น 2 ประตู 2 เครื่อง
อ๋ออ๋อ
อโอเคโอเคนะครับถ้าความต้องการในการใช้
งานแล้วผมแนะนำให้คุณลูกค้าซื้อแบบ 4
ประตูจะดีกว่าครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่ามี
เครื่องทำงานแค่เครื่องเดียวการใช้ไฟใช้
พลังงานก็จะถูกกว่าถูกกว่าการมีตู้เย็น 2
เครื่องอือ่าใช่ครับอือฮึอ๋อถึงว่าทำไม
ค่าไฟที่บ้านแม่แพงมากอเพราใช้ตู้เย็น 2
เครื่องใช่มตู้เย็น 2 เครื่องแล้วเครื่อง
เก่าด้วยอ่าน้องการกินไฟล่ะคะครับ 2
ประตูกับ 4 ประตูและ 1 ประตูเนี่ยการกิน
ไฟต่างกันยังไงอ่าอัตราการกินไฟจะใกล้
เคียงกันแต่แต่ตู้เย็นที่ใหญ่กว่าก็ต้อง
กินไฟมากกว่าอยู่แล้วครับเพราะว่าเขาทำ
ความเย็นในพื้นที่ที่เยอะเยอะกว่าอืเอ๊ะ
แล้วถ้า 2 ประตูกับ 1 ประตูครับ 1 ประตู
กินไฟมากกว่ามั้ยคะอ้า 1 ประตูก็จะกินไฟ
เอ่อจริงๆแล้ว 1 ประตูเนี่ยมันทำความเย็น
ในพื้นที่ที่เล็กกว่าแต่ว่ามันเปิดปิด
บ่อยๆใช่แต่เวลาเปิดเนี่ยจะเปิดทั้งบาน
ค่ะอ่าแต่ถ้า 1 ประตู 2 ประตูก็จะเปิดแค่
แค่ชั้นล่างที่เราเปิดหรือชั้นบนที่เรา
เปิดเท่านั้นอืทุกครั้งที่คุณลูกค้าเปิด
ตู้เย็นเย็นความเย็นในตู้เย็นก็จะออกไป
ข้างนอกค่ะอ่าแล้วเวลาปิดตู้เย็นก็ต้องทำ
งานใหม่ทำงานให้ความเย็นในตู้เย็นกลับมา
เย็นเท่าเดิมฉะนั้นก็คือจะจะกินไฟใช่
เพิ่มขึ้นอ๋องั้นถ้า 4 ประตูก็ดีกว่า 4
ถ้า 4 ประตูเปิดเล็กๆเลยใช่ก็เลือกเปิด 4
ช่องเปิดช่องที่ 1 ช่องที่ 2 ช่องที่ 3
ช่องที่ช่องไหนก็ได้ค่ะอือฮึแต่บางครั้ง
บางครั้งเราเปิดมาแล้วอ้าไม่ได้ยช่องนี้
ปิดแล้วเปิดอีกช่อง
นึงก็กินไฟเหมือนกันถ้าเราเปิดบ่อยอ่า
อ๋อโอเคเข้าใจแล้วงั้นถ้า 2 ประตูก็ดี
กว่า 1 ประตูนะคะซื้อ 1 เครื่องก็กินไฟ
น้อยกว่าใช่ครับ 2 เครื่องเครื่องใช่อ้อ
เอ่อเวลาที่ซื้อตู้เย็นเราต้องสังเกตอัน
นี้นะครับน่าที่เฉพาะที่ประเทศไทยนะ
ประเทศไทยจะมีอันนี้เราเรียกว่า 1  2  3
4  5 ตลากประหยัดไฟอ่าเพื่อที่จะบอกว่า
บอกว่าตู้เย็นเนี่ยกินไฟมากหรือกินไฟน้อย
อันไหนกินไฟมากอันไหนกินไฟน้อยค่ะอ่าถ้า
อันนี้เอ่อทางกรม
เอ่อกรมกระทรวงพลังงานเจะระบุมาแล้วครับ
ว่าอ่ออุปกรณ์ไฟฟ้าทุกชิ้นเต้องมีฉลากอัน
นี้แล้วก็เอ่อคนที่คนที่ขายตู้เย็นขาย
เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าเขาคก็จะพยายามพยายามทำ
ให้ตู้เย็นของเค้าเนี่ยอยู่ได้คุณภาพ
เบอร์
5 คือคือพยายามทำให้เอ่อสินค้าของเขาตู้
เย็นของเขาคกินไฟน้อยที่สุดเพราะว่าถ้า
สินค้าของเขาคกินไฟเบอร์ 4 เา้าก็จะสู้คน
อื่นไม่ได้อืยี่ห้ออื่นที่ทำให้กินไฟเอ่อ
ประหยัดไฟเบอร์ 5 เนี่ยเาก็จะขายเยอะกว่า
อ๋อครูเอกเข้าใจผิดนะเนี่ยอ่าครูเอกเคย
เข้าใจว่าเอ่อหมายความว่าเวลาที่เราปรับ
ตู้เย็นอ๋อเบอร์ 1 กินไฟน้อยเบอร์ 2 กิน
ไฟมากเบอร์ 3 เย็นมากกินไฟมากเบอร์ 4
เย็นมากกว่ากินไฟมากๆเบอร์ 5 ใช่สีแดงกิน
ไฟเยอะสุดไม่ใช่ใช่มั้ยคะอเอ่อเอ่อถ้าใน
ตู้เย็นท่านในตู้เย็นในตู้เย็นจะมีจะมี
ตัวปรับแบบนี้เหมือนกันค่ะอ่าใช่เป็นแบบ
นั้นครับมี 1  2  3  4  5 เป็นแบบนั้นแต่
ฉลากอันนี้ไม่เกี่ยวไม่เกี่ยวกับการปรับ
อืเกี่ยวกับเป็นตัววัดคุณภาพของตู้เย็น
ตู้นั้นว่ากินไฟมากหรือกินไฟน้อยอ๋ออ่า
ถ้า 5 ดีมากก็แปลว่ากินไฟน้อยใช่กินไฟ
น้อยแล้วทำงานได้ดีมากอือ
อืก็ต้องไปขออนุญาตได้ได้ใบอันนี้มาแปก
ที่ตู้เย็นใช่ใช่ครับอ่าทุกคนก็จะต้องมี
แล้วทุกคนก็จะเอ่อทุกยี่ห้อทุกคนที่ทำตู้
เย็นมาขายเขาก็จะพยายามทำให้ตู้เย็นของ
เขาคเนี่ยเอ่อกินไฟน้อยทำงานได้ดีมากเอ๊
เห็นอันนั้นนะเขาเขียนไว้ว่าค่าไฟฟ้าบาท
ต่อปีอ่าใช่ครับเอ่ออย่างเช่นตู้เย็นเขา
จะเอ่อคำนวณมาให้ว่าเราจะเสียค่าไฟกี่บาท
ใน 1 ปีอนะครับก็อาจจะอยู่ที่ประมาณเอ่อ
500 บาทถ้าเป็นตู้เย็นขนาดใหญ่ค่ะอ่าต่อ
1 ปีจ่ายค่าไฟ 500 บาทค่ะนะครับอแต่ขนาด
ของตู้เย็นก็จะต่างกันนะครับถ้าขนาดใหญ่
ก็จะกินไฟมากกว่าค่ะครับอาจจะ 800 บาทนะ
ครับหรือ 1,000 บาทสำหรับ 4 ประตูอะไร
อย่างงี้ครับค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นตู้เย็นที่ไม่
มีเบอร์ 5 นี่ก็ไม่รู้นะคะว่ากินไฟเ่า
เท่าไหร่อ่าคูตี้ก็แนะนำว่าอย่าซื้อครับ
ไปซื้ออันที่มีการรับรองอันที่กระทรวง
พลังงานรับรองแล้วว่าโอเคซื้อได้นะครับ
อ่าแบบนี้ดีกว่านะครับออโอนน้องมี 4 ให้
เลือกมั้ยสรุปว่าเวลาพี่เลือกพี่ต้อง
เลือกเบอร์ 5 เลือก 2 ประตูนะคะขนาดใหญ่
เล็กก็แล้วแต่พี่ใช่ขึ้นอยู่กับความ
ต้องการของคุณลูกค้าเลยครับว่าต้องการ
เอ่อใช้งานที่ขนาดเท่าไหร่กี่คิวครับแล้ว
สีล่ะค่ะอ่าสีคุณลูกค้าสามารถเลือกได้
ครับอ่าเรามีสีหลายสีนะครับแต่ว่าเดี๋ยว
นะวันนี้เอ่อเ่อสีที่ผมเอ่อมีให้ลูกค้าดู
เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวผมเปิดโคก็จะมีมีสีเงินค่ะ
อ่าแล้วก็สีสีบรอนทองสีบรอนใช่มั้ครับอ่า
โอเคนะครับอ้ออันที่จริงเอ่อคุณลูกค้า
สามารถเลือกตามแคตตาลอกได้ครับแล้วเดี๋ยว
อเมื่อคุณลูกค้าเลือกแล้วเนี่ยผมจะนำตู้
เย็นไปส่งให้ที่บ้านอ๋อแล้วถ้าพี่ซื้อ
แล้วเนี่ยน้องส่งฟรีมั้ยคะอ่าส่งฟรีครับ
ส่งฟรีส่งฟรีนะคะส่งฟรีแปลว่าแปลว่าอะไร
ครับแปลว่าบวก
แล้วส่งฟรีแปลว่ารวมไปแล้วไส่งฟรีโอเคส่ง
ฟรีครับสบอกพี่พี่จะได้สบายใจว่าส่ง
ฟรีแล้วจะส่งได้วันไหนคะอ่าส่งได้ทันที
เลยครับเ่าเดี๋ยวผมเช็คแผนกจัดส่งได้ครับ
อ่าประมาณประมาณ 2 วันครับอีก 2 วันผมไป
ส่งให้ที่บ้านอ๋อส่งแล้วก็ติดตั้งให้พี่
เลยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ครับใช่ครับออโอเคงั้นพี่
เอาเครื่องนี้ละค่ะเอ่อพี่ซื้อง่ายอ๋อแช่
แข็งข้างล่างเอาที่ช่องแช่แข็งอยู่ด้าน
ล่างนะจะได้ไม่ต้องก้มบ่อยปวดหลังใช่มใช่
อ่าแต่พี่อยากได้เป็นสีดำอ๋อได้ครับสีดำ
มีครับอ๋อจะได้ดูแล้วไม่รู้ว่าสกปรกเอ้ย
ไม่
ใช่เพราะว่าเพราะว่าเฟอร์นิเจอร์ในห้อง
ครัวอ่าเป็นสีดำเยอใช่ใช่มั้ย
เฟอร์นิเจอร์สีดำก็เลยต้องเป็นสีดำนะคะ
โอเคมีมั้ยคะสีดำมีครับมีครับสีดำสีดำได้
ค่ะโอเคเดี๋ยวเ่อคุณลูกค้าเอ่อกรอกใบรับ
ประกันให้ผมด้วยครับได้ค่ะอ่าเดี๋ยวผมจะ
เขียนใบรับประกันให้นะครับอ่ะในใบรับ
ประกันก็จะมีก็จะมีเอ่อชื่อนะครับที่อยู่
นะครับอ่ารหัสไปรษณีย์เบอร์โทรศัพท์อหรือ
เบอร์มือถือก็ได้นะครับเขียนลงไปมีอีเมล
ก็ใส่ให้ผมหน่อยได้ค่ะเพื่อที่จะได้รับ
ประกันตู้เย็นเครื่องนี้นะครับอือฮึงั้น
ก็พี่ก็จ่ายเงินแล้วก็เรียบร้อยแล้วใช่
มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับจ่ายเงินแล้วก็เรียบร้อย
เลยบัตรเครดิตรับมั้ยคะอ้ารับบัตรเครดิต
ด้วยครับสามารถจ่ายเป็นบัตรเครดิตได้อ้อ
เอ่อเอ่อตู้เย็นตู้นี้นะครับเอ่อทางเรา
เนี่ยรับประกันนะครับรับประกันรับประกัน
ให้เอ่อปกติตัวตู้เย็นเนี่ยเราจะรับ
ประกันเอ่อ 2
ปีนะครับตัวตู้เย็นรับประกัน 2 ปีแต่
คอเซอร์คอเซอร์คือตัวที่เอ่อหัวใจในการทำ
ความเย็นของตู้เย็นเนี่ยเฉพาะ
คอมเพรสเซอร์เรารับประกัน 10 ปีนะครับอื
อ่าเดี๋ยวถ้างั้นตู้เย็นเนี่ยก็มีอายุได้
10 ปีอ่ามากกว่า 10 ปีได้ครับแต่ว่าทาง
บริษัทของเรารับประกันให้ 10 ปีอ๋อ 10 ปี
แล้วถ้าถ้าภายใน 10 ปีเนี่ยคอมเพรสเซอร์
เสียบริษัทมาอ่าก็ยังรับประกันการซ่อมให้
ฟรีนะครับอ๋อแต่ถ้าตัวตู้เย็น 2 ปีปเสีย
พี่ต้องจ่ายเงินใช่มั้ยคะใช่ครับจ่ายเงิน
ในการค่าซ่อมนะครับส่วนค่าอะไหล่ก็ก็จ่าย
ปกติอยู่แล้วนะครับอืไอ้ปกติซ่อมแต่ละ
ครั้งแพงมั้ยคะเอ่อปกติซ่อมแต่ละครั้งไม่
แพงครับส่วนใหญ่เราก็จะเปลี่ยนอะไหล่อืนะ
ครับก็เสียค่าอะไหล่ 300 บาท 500 บาทขึ้น
อยู่กับอะไหล่ที่เสียโอเคเห็นบางคนบอกว่า
ซ่อมทีซื้อใหม่ดีกว่าอ๋อถ้าตู้เย็นที่ใช้
มานานๆแล้วอหรือถ้าจำเป็นต้องเปลี่ยน
คอมเพรสเซอร์ก็ซื้อใหม่ดีกว่าค่ะอือฮึอือ
งั้นอันนี้รุ่นนี้รุ่นใหม่นะอ่าใช่ครับ
รุ่นใหม่ครับรับประกัน 10 ปีเลยนะครับไม่
มีน้ำแข็งเกาะแน่นอนไม่มีนะคะไม่มีน้ำ
แข็งนะเพขี้เกียจมากขี้เกียจแงะน้ำแข็ง
อือฮึนะคะเออโอเครุ่นนี้อคะอะไรคะครับอ่า
รุ่นนี้ใช้มานานกี่ปีครับรุ่นเก่ารุ่น
เก่าเครื่องรุ่นเก่าที่บ้านใช้มานานโอน่า
จะ 12 ปีแล้วอ๋ออว้าว 12 ปีคุ้มมากๆครับ
คุ้มมากๆแล้วนะควรจะควรจะเอาออกไปแล้วนะ
คะโอเคค่ะงั้นอีก 2 วันนะคะครับ 2 วันพี่
รอรับที่บ้านอ่าได้จะถึงประมาณกี่โมงคะ
ตอนเช้าพี่ทำงานอ่าช่วงบ่ายได้มั้ยคะอ
เดี๋ยวคุณลูกค้าเมื่อกี้คุณลูกค้าเขียน
เบอร์โทรศัพท์ให้ผมแล้วเดี๋ยวผมโทรไปหา
คุณลูกค้าก่อนว่าจะไปถึงกี่โมงอยู่บ้านม
นะครับก่อนที่จะออกไปจะให้คนขับรถโทรไปหา
ก่อนครับได้ค่ะได้ค่ะพี่จะว่างว่างแล้ว
ไม่ทำอะไรเนี่ยก็คือหลังจาก 13:00 นอ๋อ
13:00 นไปถึง 17:00 นอือฮึโอเคเดี๋ยวผม
โน้ตโน้ตรายละเอียดให้ว่าคุณลูกค้าจะว่าง
ช่วง 13:00 นเป็นต้นไปให้กับคนขับรถเพื่อ
ที่เขาจะได้รู้ว่าจะไปส่งตอนไหนดีนะครับ
อ่างั้นก็โอเคเป็นอีก 2 วันวันนี้วัน
จันทร์อังคารพุธวันพุธนะคะตั้งแต่ 13:00
นถึง 17:00 นนะคะวันอ่าได้เลยครับโอเคค่ะ
โอเคขอบคุณมาพจ่ายเงินเลยค่ะอ่าครับอ่า
ยินดีครับตึ๊ดๆๆเรียบร้อยได้ตู้เย็นใหม่
กลับบ้านสบายใจอ่าเสียเงินไป 20,000
สบายอ่าเราซื้อเราซื้อคุณภาพครับเราซื้อ
คุณภาพซื้อความเอ่อสะดวกสบายอ่าในการัด
ความสุขอืประหยัดไฟเบอร์ 5 ด้วยนะครับ
ประดค่ะอืแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะอันวันนี้นัก
เรียนฟังเราแล้วก็รู้แล้วว่าเวลาเราจะไป
ซื้อตู้เย็นจะถามอะไรอนะคะจะถามอะไรบ้าง
จะต้องบอกอะไรเบ้างต้องนัดวันเวลาอ๋ออลืม
ที่อยู่ที่อยู่เราเขียนให้ในใบประกันรับ
ใช่แล้วใช่ครับอนะคะอืออือฮึนะคะก็เดี๋ยว
ครูเอกจะไปซื้อใหม่จริงๆนะเนี่ยครูเอก
อยากได้ตู้เย็นใหญ่
ๆดีครับดีครับประมาณเอ่อ 17 คิว 17 คิวก็
โอเคครับ 17  18  20 โอเคแล้วครับไม่เกิน
20,000 โอเคค่ะจริงๆครูเอ๋เอาตู้เย็น 2
ประตูเนี่ยไปให้คุณ
แม่ให้คุณแม่แล้วครูเอ๋อยู่ 1 ประตูแล้ว
ครูเอ๋น้ำ
แข็ง
อ่าถ้ารุ่นใหม่ไม่มีน้ำแข็งนะครับเป็น
ระบบเอ่อไม่มีน้ำแข็ง No  Frost นะครับ
ใช่ไม่ชอบน้ำแข็งมากรุ่นที่บ้านนี้ยังมี
น้ำแข็งอยู่นะคะโอเคค่ะวันนี้โอเคนะครับ
อ้าวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวเรา
กลับมาเจอกันใหม่นะครับคราวหน้าเราจะมา
เอ่อมีเรื่องอะไรมาคุยกันเดี๋ยวกลับมาติด
ตามกันครับได้ค่ะวอนนี้เรา 2 คนก็ลาไป
ก่อนแล้วครับค่ะสวัสดีพี่เอ๋สวัสดีคต
สวัสดีนบายบายบ๊าย
บาย